hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast management of research colony
of woodchucks i'm robert castle
bobrucz and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth labyrinth is a
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars contributing
to the advancement of science through
the content sharing capabilities lab
routes is a powerful advocate and
amplifying global networks and
communities we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window through any
technical problems hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Margaret or rather
her preferred name peg Batchelder dr.
Batchelder achieved her veterinary
degree in 1987 and board certification
and laboratory animal medicine in 1997
her veterinary experience has included
private practice academic research and
pharmaceutical research she has
contributed both a laboratory and animal
veterinarian as a researcher currently
she works for both Bristol Meyer as a
principal veterinary scientist her role
includes on the Animal Care and Use
Committee as attending veterinarian
providing clinical care for research
animals collaborating with the
researchers developing surgical animal
models and overseeing the animal health
assurance program I'll now turn it over
to the doctor for her presentation
can you hear me now
can you hear me yes Dustin and we'll
both continue with your presentation
okay
all right I apologize for that technical
difficulty and I hope it doesn't happen
again it just shut off on me
and so I wanted to thank everyone who's
listening for coming to learn about
woodchucks they are one of my favorite
species and I don't know your background
some of you may have had with chucks in
the past some of you may think you might
be working with them in the future or
you might just be curious about how we
handle this kind of unusual species in
the lab no matter what where you're
coming from I hope you will get
something out of this presentation maybe
even just a smile so for those who are
not familiar with the woodchuck would
chuck is marmodom own axe they have
quite a wide range in North America
through mostly the eastern United States
and up into Canada they have a number of
different names they've been called
woodchucks groundhogs little pigs or
land beavers they are not beavers but
they kind of look like beavers if you
don't look at the tail the Native
American word was up check or Woodcock
which sounds like where woodchuck came
from
they are rodents and as other rodents
they do have long continuously growing
incisors they have a short stocky body
short legs and about a half a tail their
four legs are very strong their
shoulders are strong they have large
claws and this is because they dig
tunnels they dig very complex tunnel
systems with multiple chambers they have
a sleeping area a nursery a toilet area
and a chamber just to turn around so if
they go in forwards they can get back
out forwards and they also have multiple
entrances and exits so they can get away
if somebody's chasing them or get to a
hole quickly if somebody's chasing them
outside their weight
is around 2 to 6 kilograms or up to
about 15 pounds and that depends partly
on sex and partly on season they are
hibernating species and can lose quite a
bit of their body weight during the
hibernation season during the summer you
see them in the dawn and dusk commonly
seen by the side of the road this is
called a crepuscular cycle and that's
when they are the most active and they
like to eat grass greens fruits
vegetables they are very appreciative of
people who plant gardens and put so much
lovely food in such a nice compact space
so they're not really very popular with
gardeners around here they're considered
a pest and are often hunted for sport or
just to get them away from the garden in
addition they're digging 10 damaged
foundations and you know Leopold's on
the ground which can be dangerous for
horses to step in and other problems so
they're not not very well liked in this
area the reason that they have become a
lab animal is that in 1977 it was
discovered that they can carry a virus I
called woodchuck hepatitis virus it was
discovered in 1977 and they started
doing research in 1978 this is a have
had no virus it is very similar to human
hepatitis B virus and that's what makes
it so important it is a hepatic virus it
has a very high homology with
HPV at the nucleotide level it has a
very similar similar epidemiology that
can cause a number of different diseases
both woodchucks and people it can be
totally asymptomatic it can have an
acute hepatitis they can clear the virus
or they can go into a chronic hepatitis
state and the acute hepatitis they
develop a very effective immune response
and can clear the virus completely
they the product state they do have an
immune response but it is inadequate so
they end up with a chronic active
hepatitis and cirrhosis of the liver in
the epidemiology an adult animal or
person infected with this type of virus
is more likely to have a or tur course
to build a good immune response and
actually resolve the hepatitis whereas
those who are infected at a younger age
particularly neonates have a higher
chance of developing the chronic
hepatitis
besides the chronic hepatitis a major
concern is that prolonged chronic
hepatitis can lead to you know the
cirrhosis of the liver liver failure but
also to have had a cellular carcinoma
and these pictures here on the left is a
human hepatocellular carcinoma and on
the right is a woodchuck liver with
multiple areas of hepatocellular
carcinoma so very similar type of
progression of disease in the human the
presence of chronic hepatitis from
hepatitis B gives them approximately a
hundred percent multiple risk of
developing this type of cancer and it's
the most important risk factor for
people who get hepatocellular carcinoma
in woodchucks it starts to be a 100
percent incidence of tumors if they have
the chronic State now you might think
this would kill us the woodchuck
population but interestingly it takes so
long for them to develop the cancer in
terms of their natural life cycle in the
wild they just don't live long enough to
be really affected in numbers by the
cancer they usually die from something
else first so all in all they're very
valuable research model is very
translatable to humans or viral
hepatitis and for the oncogenesis that
goes with it
and you can study the progression of
disease and they have they're looking at
treatments to prevent or even to reverse
the chronic infection and that's why we
get wood chips in the lab and that's why
we're going to be looking at how to take
care of them because because they are
such an unique model and they're also
very cute when we got woodchucks in
initially we you know did some research
the best housing we could come up with
at the time was rabbit caging and we had
a bunch of used rabbit caging and we had
them modify it a bit because we knew
that woodchucks are good doers these
cages were the type that come with the
plastic floors which are supposed to be
more comfortable for the rabbits but
they would have been destroyed by the
woodchucks and they also had plastic
feeders and we had to have metal feeders
made for them and to say what you on
those two so everything had to be
stainless steel we did keep them on wood
shavings as as a bedding its absorbent
it gives them something to play with
it helps to pad their feet from the
metal surface below in some cases the
woodchucks are very kind of toilet
trained they'll push the litter over to
the bedding over to one side and kind of
use that as a litter box and they also
use it as nesting material they'll pull
it into their into their boxes which
I'll show you in a sec and use it to try
to make a little nest and they do
urinate a lot and they have very soft
stool so you'd have to clean up after
them every day the volume that you get
depends on the season and they do drop
some in the winter season but they do
need to be cleaned daily and then we did
a full change out once or twice a week
where we completely took all the bedding
out and replaced it inside the cages we
had what we called mail boxes these are
shelters that are approximately the size
of a woodchuck tunnel the woodchucks
really love these they like to just sit
in them and they look out on the world
from the doorway and most of the time if
you walked in the room you're going to
find most of the woodchucks inside the
mailboxes so it it was something that
they liked it's something that made it
easier to clean the cages because you
could actually slide a flat steel plate
in these grooves here there's a group
here and here on the side so you can
just slide a flat steel plate right down
in there and lock them in the box and
then you can take them out clean the
cage and then just kind of put them back
in with a clean box you can also lock
them in there and use it to carry them
down the hall to the lab that's why we
have the handles on top here and we even
had some latches although we didn't
usually have to latch them they kind of
like being in the box and they're
usually pretty quiet so they were
convenient for us and woodchucks like
them again all stainless steel and when
we were reading up before we got that
woodchucks we weren't sure whether they
were a social species or not the reading
that we did suggested that adult
woodchucks are pretty solitary they
don't like to be together especially
males with males and that it was not
advisable to house them in a small cage
together just in a large area they might
get along but we found out that our
woodchucks had different ideas at least
the girls and some of our females
preferred to be with another female and
the these two actually took the divider
out between their two adjacent cages and
decided that they wanted to cuddle up in
the same tunnel I was amazed I did not
think that two woodchucks would fit in
that mailbox but obviously they did
so if you have woodchucks in the future
it would be a good idea to try out
pairing some of the females I don't
think I tried the male's even offseason
but feel free to try if you want to the
bird quite a few challenges I mentioned
that the gnawing behavior so everything
had to be stainless steel or replaced
all the time
[Music]
one woodchuck was was very industrious
and decided to break the welds on the
caging and and bend the wires down which
you can see over on the left and and
they could also escape through any hole
they could get their head through so
they would knock the feeders out and
then squeeze out through the feeder hole
they could actually flex these wire
doors enough so that the latch would be
in the in the middle and they would push
the top or the bottom enough to flex it
and be able to squeeze out that way so
they were very strong they're very
persistent and they have a very high
very high desire to get out of the cages
you can see on the right-hand picture
here this girl was sitting up on top
they are very good climbers and I don't
know whether you get that video working
but this would be the time to show it if
it's working
okay it doesn't look like our video is
working so unfortunately it's it's how
this girl got out she actually went over
to the latch she chewed on it she pushed
it with her paw until it slid over and
then flipped it over and then jumped on
the door until it opened so she just
opened the door and and find out what's
interesting in her case the door
actually is what holds the floor pan in
place the floor pan is the roof of the
cage below so when she got out and left
the door open
the woodchuck in the cage underneath
figured out that he could push that
floor forward his ceiling forward and he
did that and he climbed up up the back
inside to her cage and then he could get
out - fortunately for us these animals
don't breed year-round or we might have
had some unexpected babies and they are
also a real challenge to catch they do
not like to be caught so they will run
around the room they're very good at
avoiding you they like to go under
things they climb on top of things
they could actually jump from the top of
one cage rack to the other and in some
cage racks we actually did have a
separate floor in ceiling and between
the cages one on top of the other and
they would squeeze it to that small area
between the floor and the ceiling they
avoided Nets they didn't want to go into
their mail boxes and they were basically
really hard to catch them and they
seemed quite proud of themselves when
they got out so as far as I'm taking
care of these guys
in the wild they eat grasses and fruits
and vegetables so we feed them a rabbit
diet which is you know they can either
plain rabbit diet or there's a woodchuck
diet that is basically a rabbit diet but
if the pellets are a little bigger
that's what we usually feed them as
their basic diet but we supplemented
with a lot of fruits and vegetables and
they really really like these little
carrots and that's what we use as a
reward when they were good when we had
to take them out for a blood draw or
something they got little carrots when
they came back but there were other
things that they liked as well
we the woodchucks can drink from a crack
a water bottle or automatic watering the
ones that we got in were not trained for
automatic watering so we would start
them with a crock but we kept the video
camera on them and watched them and they
eventually did figure out how to use the
automatic watering so you just have to
give them time to get used to it we
didn't try water bottles if you do use
water bottles they will knock them on
the floor so we just didn't go that
route but they're pretty smart despite
the name woodchuck card ciders this is
not an appropriate beverage for
woodchucks I just wanted to point that
out in case you see this not an
appropriate beverage I mentioned that
they're hibernating species and
light-cycle is very important to them
for determining the time of year they
even if they don't go into hibernation
they will have a metabolic cycle so if
you keep them in a normal animal room
they will still cycle their weights will
go up and down their appetites will go
up and down with the season because the
this is a natural cycle that's built
into them and it's approximately a year
line but some are a little longer
somewhere a little less so if you keep
them on a light cycle that's the same
all the time they'll start to drift so
over a year or two you'll start to see
some that are a slightly shorter light
cycles they'll be getting their cycle a
little bit earlier and the other one
a little later and they get out of sync
because we didn't want our colony to get
out of sync we used a seasonal light
cycle adjustments so they would at least
I'll be going into their quiet period
their metabolic period at the same time
you can't get rid of it all together but
at least you can keep them the same for
the year animals are in the same part of
their cycle so we just adjusted the
lights based on the time outside the Sun
was up
if you really want them to go into full
hibernation you need the light cycle you
also need to lower the room temperature
considerably and restrict their food and
with those cues they will go into a full
hibernation we didn't want them to do
that so we just kept them on that cycle
to keep them in sync and they do lose a
lot of weight they their activity
decreases they eat less this less
species they can lose up to 50% of their
body weight between the summer and the
hibernation period as with other species
I would like to provide environmental
enrichment we like to have them perform
species typical behaviors which in their
case is mostly sitting in their little
hutches you can't really provide them a
substrate to tunnel but they dig around
in the shavings and like I said some of
them will actually use them to build a
nest inside their hutches and they are
very food motivated especially in the
summer spring and summer when they would
normally be eating their heads off and
they enjoyed fruit fruits such as
cantaloupe that was a big favorite and
over here on the left you can see Suzie
just gobbling down that cantaloupe she
just loved it and the carrots as I
mentioned the little guy in the middle
and they also liked cereals and crackers
and things like that and we actually
were feeding some cereal we had some
lucky charms if you're familiar with
that it's a it's a serial but it's got
little pieces of marshmallow in it and
Susie decided she liked the marshmallow
better than the cereal and she would
pick all the marshmallows out and wait
until they were are gone before she
would actually eat the cereal and if you
just gave her cereal she would turn up
her nose
so they have different personalities and
another thing that you can use for
enrichment is hey you can give them
fresh grass from outside so there's
other things that you can add in and
different different woodchucks like
different things so it kind of you know
depends on their personality as well as
what's going on outside in the season
restraining woodchucks is another
challenge they are difficult to handle
they're very defensive and they're even
the lab reared ones still have some
degree of wild animal in them
occasionally they're actually aggressive
and they'll jump towards you but usually
it's more defensive behavior they have
very long sharp teeth they have long
claws and very strong legs and can cause
some pretty nasty injuries and so you
don't want to have that happen they're
hard to grab ahold of they have a thick
heavy body with really muscular
shoulders but the skin is very mobile
it's got a lot of subcutaneous fat and
it just kind of slides around so it's
very hard to get a good hold on them if
you're just grabbing the skin their legs
are very short and the tail is not real
long either but you can grab the tail
and you can pick them up briefly by the
tail you don't want to do that for a
long period of time because they will
flip around and climb up their own tails
to get your hand but it's good to kind
of swing them up onto another surface or
into a box or something like that the
other reason not to hold them by the
tail very long is that the contents of
their gastrointestinal tract are very
heavy and you don't
to have that sitting on their diaphragm
and potentially you know pressing on
their ability to breathe but we would in
this case where we had wake animals we
had a restrainer built and this was a a
tube that was again kind of like a
tunnel we would guide lift the animals
up onto the table quickly by the tail
use a gloved hand to guide them into the
restrainer it was only made to cover the
front part of the animal so that was the
big stride front claws and the teeth so
that would keep them keep those handlers
safer it would keep the animal fairly
quiet because they were in a tunnel and
that's how we handled them when they
were awake this was a device that we had
custom-made as you can see it's strapped
to the table because they do wiggle and
they can easily kick that whole thing
right off the table but for most
procedures such as a physical exam
something like that if you tried to get
blood from a vein you really need to
anesthetize them so we we primarily used
I saw foreign gas anesthesia in a
chamber as you can see on the left and
they would you know go down in the
chamber and then you could maintain them
on a face mask you can use injectable
anesthetics also we did sometimes use
Taylor salt excuse me to you at all
but we did like the gas anesthesia
because they will wake up very quickly
if you ever need to sex a woodchuck it's
actually not too hard
they are like many other species have a
pretty pretty decent difference in their
anal genital distance this is a male on
the left and you can see it's about this
far between the genital and the anus and
the female it's just a short period
this guy you can see his testicles under
the skin this is he's a breeding season
which is only a few months in the spring
most of the rest of the year you would
not really see those testicles there
there they would retract it to the body
they're very small so they only are
prominent in during the breeding season
so I mentioned vascular access under
anesthesia there are a number of
different vessels that you can access
the cephalic vein in the front leg it's
very small as in that's a very short leg
but you can access that we like to put a
little catheter in there rather than
just trying to tap it directly with the
needle but you could do either depending
on the volume of blood you needed they
also on the hind legs inside the hind
leg you can access the femoral vessels
femoral vein and you can also if you
feel confident doing a free stick a kind
of a blind stick in the jugular area you
can try to get blood from the jugular
vein and the neck they don't have a true
jugular vein it's actually the
anastomosis of the lingual facial and
maxillary veins but it's a lot easier to
say jugular so that's what we call it
even though technically it's not a
jugular vein you can kind of see that in
the picture on the right here the arrow
kind of points to what you would think
would be a jugular vein it's an
anastomosis of two vessels and but I
really put this up because we had
studies where we needed to do multiple
IV dosing we needed multiple blood
samples and rather than have to keep
anesthetize any animals and hitting
veins we did implant vascular access
ports into most of our animals and I'll
be talking about that more tomorrow but
we found that this was not too hard to
do and once they went in it was much
much easier
to access the animals they did not have
to be anesthetized we would put them in
that respirator and this is why it was
only a half of restrainer we wanted the
hind end out and I can assure you you
probably see but I'll just point it out
and this is where the port is under the
skin and then you just access it
percutaneously with a needle and a line
and then you can draw the blood up or
you can dose if you need to dose either
way we did put both arterial and venous
ports in some animals had both some had
just the the arterial port which is more
for collecting blood rather than dosing
and we had pretty good success with them
I mean they stayed many of them were
painting for quite a while until the
animals were euthanized so we found that
quite convenient and it was it was worth
the effort of surgically putting the
ports in oral dosing is a cinch very
easy to orally dose a woodchuck they
have a large gap between their front
incisors and their back chewing teeth
called the diastema and all you have to
do is put a metal feeding needle kind of
a long one four to six inches long on a
syringe and put the tip of that needle
right behind their incisors and just put
in whatever liquid you need to put in
and they're pretty adaptable to that you
can see you don't have to restrain them
at all they're just sitting in their
little hutch and you put it in there is
something called liquid woodchuck diet
which is something kind of a thick
liquid kind of like pancake batter kind
of smells like pancake batter I've heard
it tastes like pancake batter but I
never actually tried it myself but the
woodchucks will really love this and you
can see the woodchuck on the right is
actually trying to pull the syringe away
from the researcher because he wants to
get all of it so they really like this
woodchuck diet so you can
as a carrier for any other liquid
medication if you need to or you can put
powders and mix it in because it's a
pretty thick liquid so that's another
good way to give them oral doses you can
do injections I am injections sub-q
injections but then of course we have to
handle the animal so we we tried to do
oral as much as possible and medical
issues some of our animals were wild
caught some were lab reared so we had
different issues depending on their
background wild-caught animals could
have parasites specifically we would see
coccidia they could have tapeworms if we
got them from a vendor they would
usually have already treated them for
tapeworms so we didn't often see that
but we did see coccidia they needed
several treatments sometimes to get rid
of those so that's one thing that we
would definitely treat right off the bat
they could come in with various kinds of
wounds or scars if it was an active
wound and open wound you can give them
antibiotics again the oral antibiotics
in some type of a liquid suspension is
the easiest way to do it for some of
these larger open wounds that are not
real deep but they just kind of like an
abrasion or a flat wound and we would
just put wonder dust on it this is an
antibiotic powder and it just kind of
helps dry the wound out and it also acts
you know as an antibiotic which it is
and we found that pretty successful
sometimes they would come in with the
Poteau dermatitis so the bottoms of
their feet would have ulcers on them
those are very hard to treat we
obviously would give them antibiotics
and try bandaging the feet just to kind
of give them some extra protection from
the stainless steel flooring we like to
use colloid bandage
which you can you know pick up at the
drugstore and that helps to keep the
area moist so they can heal but not not
too moist you don't want to you know
soaking wet and you can do the bandage
changes usually it's the back feet so
you can do the bandits changes in that
restrain air with their front end to
protect it and their back feet out where
you can reach them unfortunately they do
not tend to heal well the ones one that
we had was pretty bad when it came in
when we first got it this is a wild
caught animal and we never were able to
get it to heal basically this animal
lived in bandages the whole time we have
it and now once they're in the lab there
they can also get this pota dermatitis
and we did have one that develops well
we had it but he he cleared up pretty
well so I think if you catch it early
enough it's a lot easier to treat and we
put more bedding in his cage so that he
had a little more padding from the
floors antibiotics and he seemed to come
along quite well they can also get some
wounds even though we didn't you know
allow them to get together and fight
sometimes they would get themselves well
they could get out for one thing and
they could hurt themselves that way but
they would push their faces through the
door or then kind of scratch up their
noses sometimes and we had a number of
them develop something at the base of
the tail we're not really sure what it
was but because it was multiple animals
in the similar location we think it
might have been something maybe
physiologic in there it reminded me of
cats that have something called stud
tail it's a cumulation of a body of
secretions from the skin and it gets
kind of irritated you the hair gets lost
and that's kind of what these look like
they would lose their hair it would just
be a kind of large slightly ulcerated or
reddened area and we would treat those
mostly topically that was a good a good
way to use the wonder dust and again I
think it might have been something
physiologic hormone or something like
that but we never really could figure
out what was causing it didn't seem to
be from injury because it was at a place
on the body that doesn't really contact
much of anything in the research related
medical issues and there were several
especially in the hepatitis positive
animals because they could have liver
disease in addition some of the animals
were getting quite a few blood draws so
between a liver disease and a lot of
blood drives
we had some cases of anemia based on the
results of the blood tests
the CBC we could it looked like it was
an iron deficiency anemia
in these particular cases so we think it
was a combination anemia from liver
disease anemia from blood draws and
probably not enough iron in their diet
we don't really know exactly how much
iron they need in their diet but with
all the blood draws it seemed that they
were losing too much iron we would give
them some iron dextran and they would
come right around so that worked really
well they can have also clotting
disorders because their livers are not
creating enough clotting factors and
those we didn't see any clinical
problems with it but if we were doing
surgery we would give them some vitamin
K before surgery just to kind of give
them that little edge in case they had a
tendency to have a bleeding problem so
that was just something we did
prophylactically but we never saw any
clinical signs if you let the liver go
on to a more serious state they could
have other problems
low blood glucose seizures those those
can be problems as the livers get more
and more diseased we did that actually
need the animals to get to that point so
as soon as we thought they were starting
to get tumors we would we would usually
euthanize them at that point so they
didn't have to suffer the way we figured
out whether they were having problems
with by tracking their blood work
looking at liver enzymes and in
particular the GGT enzyme which I don't
remember what it stands for but it's GGT
that enzyme is very predictive of when
they get liver cancer so it would be you
know baseline baseline baseline and then
it would start to creep up and when we
saw creeping up we would watch them very
carefully
and it could go from you know our limit
of detection was about two it could go
up to fifty seventy a hundred or even
higher and at that point we were pretty
confident that they had liver tumor even
if they weren't showing any signs so at
that point we would usually euthanize
them because you know they we didn't
need them to be at that state so those
are kind of research related or whv
related diseases so that is pretty much
all I had to say about you know basic
care of the species and there's tons
more but I think I'll open it up to
questions and so that you know we can
see what specifically you're interested
in knowing so anyone has any questions
feel free to join in now well thank you
so very much doctor for your
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the low and left of
the presentation window we're going to
try to answer as many questions as we
can our first question for you is can
describe how you pair them for mating do
they injure each other during mating
well we actually did not mate animals
and we were not trying to breed them
they have we talked with other labs that
do mating and they don't really have a
problem with that they're generally
pretty affiliative the male's will seek
out the females and the females will
seek out the males so I have not heard
of them having any kind of injury from
mating they do only mate once a year so
and so they're only interested in each
other in the spring february-march if
they're outdoors in our next question is
where do you get the woodchucks well
that's a good question when we first
learned that we needed woodchucks they
were required by the FDA for this
particular study because there it's kind
of the model for HPV studies and we
looked into a number of options
including trapping them you know buying
them from a vendor trying to get them
from animal Patrol places that trapped
animals for a living and then maybe they
would give them to us one thing we found
out is that not all woodchuck
populations have woodchuck appetite as
virus so in our area which is
Connecticut most of the woodchucks do
not have this virus if you want to trap
animals in the wild you want to go to
parts of Pennsylvania New Jersey
Maryland a little further down on the
Atlantic seacoast and that's where it's
endemic in the population so we we
didn't really think we were going to do
that there is a vendor he actually works
out of Idaho but he comes east and he
traps woodchucks and takes them back and
he'll do the conditioning he will deworm
them he will you know take blood samples
you often need to know whether an animal
chronically infected or not so you want
to take multiple blood samples over a
period of time to be sure that they're
not just going through an acute phase of
the disease so he will do all of that
and then he'll sell them to you for a
large sum of money so that's that's an
option he there are not very many
woodchuck vendors out there that will do
that
so he's pretty much our only option
there was a vendor in Canada but we felt
that it would be impractical for us to
try to import the woodchucks across
country lines and it was easier to just
stay within the United States in one
case we were desperate for woodchucks
right away so he actually came directly
from his trapping run and gave us some
woodchucks that were wild caught that he
had just caught and had got conditions
them at all so we did have some wild
caught woodchucks
we had some trapped woodchucks and we
also had some woodchucks that had been
trapped as pregnant females which he had
taken back to his lab and then he would
raise the pups in the lab he could
actually really infect the pups manually
inject them with the woodchuck hepatitis
virus to increase the chances that they
will develop that chronic disease so you
can raise them that way and no increase
the percentage of them that will be
positive so we have had all three okay
and plastic before we let you go today
doctor is there any closing remarks
right now well I just I hope this was
interesting I hope it was useful to
people who might be getting woodchucks
in the future who have woodchucks now
and I hope it was at least interesting
to those who were just curious about
this species and I appreciate you all
coming to here thank you thank you
doctor again for your time in your
outstanding presentation I also like to
thank lab reeds for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 20
team you'll receive an email from
laberd's alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who have may have missed
today's live event and until next time
goodbye